[Music]
Pete you reviewed crash in Saint Joe to
get into it mm-hmm yay let's get into
this give it a six out of ten I did a
little bit of backlash us a little which
is weird because everything I see on
Twitter from people who like really like
I don't know they said the first game is
really bad now second one is probably
the high point third is not is that the
was that your take yeah the second one
seems to have just the best little like
variety by the time you get to the third
it's just yeah it's interesting though
because everybody seems to acknowledge
that like one of the games in that
trilogy the remaster children is good
yet they still think that like it's a
faithful homage to the original games
which I guess like we wanted to talk
more about after I get some of your
thoughts on the review whether this is
needed to exist outside of nostalgia but
but anyway first I want to ask you so
overall kind of broad strokes if people
haven't read your review or watched it
what you think I think as far as a you
know remaster slash remake goes you
couldn't really ask for this game to
look any better you know Vicarious
Visions did a really good job of just
sort of modernizing what crashes but
crash is also a very simple game and one
that I don't think really stands the
test of time I think if you didn't play
crash bandicoot and you didn't have a
nostalgia for this and he started to
play it today you would probably think
well this is a pretty simple game
doesn't really do anything interesting
yeah you know crash has great
personality some of the level designs
are okay but by and large it's it's a
very simple game and one that's
antiquated at this point his fur looks
too real for this kind of animation it
looks weird it's it's a bit strange I
mean it looks super modern but it plays
like an old game yeah yeah and then I
did want to talk just in general because
I think it was last year John Luke when
the Bioshock remastered collection came
out he was saying like when there are
certain cases were and like with those
games sometimes remasters can hurt a
game the things they sacrifice and
whether they actually are faithful or
are too faithful in this case did you
think that there was an opportunity or a
missed opportunity to maybe expand on
the original games formulas made
obviously that wasn't really what they
were going for but yeah I mean if you
think
if you just want to judge the game based
on what the developers were going for
mm-hmm and they did a great job of doing
that but if but I think you say does it
remain too faithful well I think maybe
in some parts you know like one of the
things that people have been giving me
crap about is that in my review I say
like there are points in this game where
it's just like you can make it super far
into a level and there's one jump but
that's just like super super like there
could the constraint for success versus
failure is really tight and you can lose
you know a lot of lives very quickly
some people said oh the games too hard
six out of ten well no but I do think
it's uneven at points and that was the
the point that I was trying to make is
that this game just kind of very
abruptly introduces something that just
seems incongruous with everything I did
before door after it in the same level
and I think some of that could have been
evened out it's not a matter of I
couldn't beat the game it's a matter of
wow this is this is not consistent and
it just seems almost like an accident
rather than something that's been
thoughtfully designed from top to bottom
Felipe I'd are in the twitch chat was
saying it is weird that they updated the
physics but not the level design is that
accurate is that how you felt with a
level design they have not the physics
I'm not quite sure what they're
referring to I do know that like yes you
can use the analog stick now mm-hmm in
addition to the d-pad which I actually
felt was kind of strange because a lot
of these level designs were created for
you know the sort of very clean controls
of a d-pad where you need to you know
step accurately to the right of the left
or forward or backward depending on the
mission you're in because it could be
you know you're running from a boulder
and you have to very accurately navigate
pathways that get more narrow yeah and I
so I thought the analog controls were
like a nice touch in some areas but
almost like not worth using the whole
time yeah well it's a little strange but
the physics specifically I don't know
someone said they unified the jump
physics across all three games kind of
like like I don't know like I've
recently guided Metro redux they took
like the last light physics and graphics
and implemented them on 2033 I can I can
understand that it's and so long since
I've played the original is that I just
didn't notice that that change and you
wonder what went into that decision when
you're thinking about like how those
physics originally affected two or
threes level design maybe you're like
yeah sure right
yeah hitbox detection with the boxes or
enemies or whatnot
this the detection I'm sure that that
that's fine but it's more or less than
measurement of you know the the layout
of a level yeah like how things line up
and the distance between them and the
timing required to hit those yeah like
it's it's a fine game and you know I'm
seeing everyone who really loves crash
they still really like this hmm
I like to crash when I you know when it
came out and the first three games are
still relevant I don't know I just
thought it was okay it's tough to say
because you would you know you are if
you're a huge fan of the trilogy it
wouldn't be a bad thing if they just
completely remade it right like resin
will remake is one of the better remakes
ever I always like that that's a
different thing right they're not just a
remastering if they're actually kind of
rebooting it a little bit or a Ratchet
and Clank last year on ps4 they took the
original game but they borrowed a bunch
of really good aspects from the later
games from the Future trilogy and from
just the rest of like up your arsenal
going commando there's so many like
innuendo remake I never played any of
those games prior but like red flags one
of my favorite games and I agree that's
it was a very it a cherry picked what
worked right like yeah and and then also
threw in like really great controls like
I forgot what it er a ssin you were
telling me where they were they finally
steered away or steered towards the like
aiming watch while like strafing and
jump yeah like that like they didn't
have to do that
it was pure third-person like from
ratchets perspective in the first game
and then in going commando the second
one you the option to turn on strafe and
reticle and the third one yeah up your
arsenal that was the base but yeah they
upgrade they updated that to actually
not be a pure third-person game anymore
in the first game but you you yeah like
you as someone who had never played the
first game got into it because of that
remake last year Oh totally
yeah and just you know I think crash had
like the similar like you know as far as
showing the really nice blending of
motion and motion blur mm-hmm I don't
know like that makes everything
worthwhile and you know that you know
you look at something like crash and
like you see that it looks great but
like you know hearing Peter talk about
how it felt you know they did not update
the controls right like no no they did
update the controls but the level design
wasn't there to meet the update yeah but
you know again another key point
understand is like something like
Ratchet and Clank even if they just did
a remaster right like those games were
still they came out of
when 3d platforming action had kybun
figured out Crash Bandicoot was made
when those things hadn't really been
figured out and standards have changed
quite a bit yeah right well that's
that's the question right when you're
going back to something like Gears of
War a couple years ago with the Ultimate
Edition before four came out like it's
that's always a challenge with three
masters like do you want to stay
faithful or do you want to update it for
modern palates in a way that like it's
not just you know like rose tinted
glasses you're actually playing
something that's fun with everything
that's come out after the original
release like I don't know kiala you
reviewed Ukulele earlier this year and I
know you're a big fan of first and
foremost banjo tooie but also kazooie
kind of to a lesser extent but ukulele I
think is another prime example of 3d
platformers are kind of you know outside
of Mario games and I mean Ratchet and
Clank Stern extended I'm sure I'm
missing a bunch but they've kind of
faded to the periphery as opposed to
what they were you know what the advent
of 3d ukulele did it feel that kind of
game feel as irrelevant or even like
kind of like did you feel like it was
dated because they were sticking too
closely to the original 3d platformer
formula yeah it definitely felt dated I
think the the biggest issue with ukulele
is that they were trying to meet the
fans where they were instead of kind of
bringing the fans to something you know
new or inventive so it was very you know
run-of-the-mill it felt like banjo
kazooie with a reskin and a you know a
more finicky camera so there were a lot
of things that didn't work for me there
were a lot of things that were fun I do
like the I mean I had the the
collectathon kind of thing this is
something that that was nostalgic for me
but I think that they just didn't
execute it well because it was so close
to what I expected from banjo kazooie
like I didn't have to try very hard to
to go through the levels because I was
like well I've played magic with zhu-li
a thousand times I know exactly what I'm
looking for and I know what all the
secrets are already they didn't bring
anything new and the camera it was a
mess which sucks because that's kind of
what can make or break a 3d platformer
they to be fair they did patch it out
when I reviewed it it was it was pretty
wonky I think this is my gameplay even
where I was like I don't I can't even
see I look like I'm really bad at this
kind of game because
the the the it's like the depth
perception is off or something and so
this is another case we're like if I
misjudged a jump or like there were
times where like I couldn't get high
enough like a platform looked like I
could reach it from you know down below
but then I would jump and I couldn't
reach it and stuff like that and so the
dated aspects combined with the
technical missteps just made it kind of
an unfortunate it's it looked like they
finally is like I was ahead of pretty
big like patch or update for this game I
think last week and the one that stuck
out to me because I remember playing
this was something was really
frustrating was that gibberish no he
said they kept making yeah like I that
was like that was almost a deal-breaker
alone just that that constant babbling
was so loud and obnoxious that maybe
works you know in the last games like
but now it's super annoying so anyways
the update I think you were able to like
skip it or turn it off or something yeah
they did update it where you could like
go really quickly through dialogue or
turn it off there's there's some sort of
option but honestly like I have no
desire to really revisit it now that I'm
done in the game yeah Michael hi um
actually went down to Irvine recently at
Blizzard to play starcraft remastered I
know Starcraft 2 has how many expansions
now three is it I think two or three and
that was another case where we saw you
know the remaster was kind of announced
and of course now it's like actually you
know it's been it is gonna fit modern
graphics and everything it still looks
pretty faithful to the original game but
you know it's kind of picking Michael's
brain and it sounds like it's you know
doing enough to actually you know kind
of tap in that nostalgia but also to
still feel like a game that can be
played today yeah and you know you have
to wonder because the RTS is another one
with genres which they're still good RTS
games coming out last year Warhammer
40000 dawn of war 3 God that titles a
mouthful that was actually really good
game I played that and I liked it a lot
I know David you it over in the UK it
plays a lot of RTS games still but I
maybe it's just different subgenres and
like P like you said crash was that the
advent of like kind of three
for me I was naughty ugh first outing
from the mistaken somewhere yeah
and they're still trying to figure
things out and of course you know like
before they got the jack and dexter and
then there's some like platforming
aspect still uncharted but you have to
wonder whether crash the insane trilogy
actually there was much reason for it to
come outside a nostalgia like yeah is it
relevant anymore that that kinda goes
back to my point like if this game came
out it wasn't called crash bandicoot i
don't think people would give two shits
yeah I play crash in uncharted 4 and
that was enough for me I don't know any
other remasters and I'm missing that
like might like like I said there's
really a video on GameSpot John Luke did
about the Bioshock collection and how
those kind of almost like hurt the
original games in terms of updating them
for 2016 but uh you can look to three
yes the the work on starfox 64 and 3ds
in particular is really good yeah terms
of remaster in those same or Ocarina and
the door as well but Star Fox 64 stood
out more Majora's Mask I was really
happy because they updated the bosses so
it was a lot yeah so but it was still
faith like it was modernizing it enough
to where like they fixed the problems
that that game had with bosses but also
it was still faithful to the original
yeah I did a really good job with
Majora's Mask Katrina like just like
even just think about the water temple
how they updated that and move the iron
boots to an item slot as opposed to
equipment so you have to pause all the
time yeah yeah that was really like it's
a very small change that doesn't affect
your like your you know whatever you're
fond memory is about it it greatly
enhances the experience returning to it
and then Wind Waker HD is another
example of like adding the Swift sail
and getting rid of that really
frustrating in sequence like the
Triforce thing yeah yeah where you're
you know honey you have to like sail
around and it takes forever I'm adding
the Swift sail was really smart yeah
that's something that like I was really
frustrated with in like Omega Ruby and
alpha sapphire for Pokemon like I didn't
update any of the travel you have to
it's just so frustrating it's like so
bogged down at the end yeah and I'm like
I'd like talking to you about the stuff
P because you as someone who like puts a
lot of time into looking into like game
preservation and you
a lot of older games and everything so
there's always that fine line between
you know is this game good today and no
but it's still a faithful like maybe
preservation of the original game it's
kind of it must be a fine line to walk I
mean I know you're not making these
games but from your perspective as
someone who plays a lot of them and
collects a lot of the original versions
yeah I was wondering like what they were
probably thinking when they were doing
the crash insane trilogy like they've
gone so far to make it look so good and
then they just adhere to again dated
sort of levels and and stuff like that
like they must part of them must have
felt like can't we just do something new
with it you know like maybe we'll see
that I mean maybe the work they've done
is just the foundation for something
else cool
[Music]